looking at your IMDB you have 31 or so
producing credits I'm sure going to be
more at the time of this release so
which production taught you the most Wow
I learned a lot on so many of the
different movies that I've done so it
depends on you know what what did I
learn
I made I've made a lot of movies and I
think that the ones that have taught me
the most are I made a movie called
Havenhurst that one told me a lot it was
a horror to me to the horror film it was
very difficult and I realized there are
many things that I will not do again so
that's a great thing to learn great
movie I'm very you know the movie
ultimately ended up being very good but
the experience for me as a filmmaker was
as a producer was not a great one the
things that I've learned the most I
think I mean I've made have made a lot
of movies I think ultimately the best
lesson that I've learned which is making
from making the passion flicks movies is
that I need to enjoy the experience from
start to finish because it is very hard
to make a movie and it costs a lot of
money and if you're not enjoying it then
there is no reason to do it so I learned
that maybe from making some of these
movies prior to this prior to passion
flicks realizing that if I'm not in from
from you know hindsight I did not enjoy
making a lot of those movies and I do
enjoy making the passion of six movies
they're fulfilling they make me happy I
can't wait to make the next one whereas
prior to that I was not enjoying them it
was more of a job and not to say that
they were bad experiences that they were
I made some great movies and I really
enjoyed the people and fortunately
actually now with Patra flakes I get to
bring so many of those people on to my
productions but sometimes when you're
working for other people and you're
you're getting notes from from them
they're not necessarily the notes that I
would probably say this sometimes
their interpretation of what the movie
should be is not my interpretation of
what the movie should be and that is
filmmaking I mean that's that's the
creative process I don't necessarily
want to show woman in a certain light
and so I didn't enjoy that specific film
and now I get to show a woman in the
light that I like to show them so it
makes me happy I just like to have
positive experiences something I think
that's the important thing the tiki bar
TV which was a podcast that I did a
video podcast that I did was a perfect
example of making something and really
enjoying it every single time you made
it because it was funny and the people
were great and so now I get to do that
again
every time you should if you please do
come to one of our sets when we make the
next one we are laughing and joking and
having the best time the crew that I
have on all of my movies are almost the
same crew for the last year they just
come they transplant back to my they all
come to my new new sets because we have
great experiences and it's just so much
fun the environment is so important
environments vital especially it's
high-pressure it's time-sensitive and
and you have to be creative within these
confines and and we don't have the
luxury yet of being able to say oh we'll
just do it tomorrow or we'll just pick
it up and that's just lengthen the
timeframe for this movie we need to
shoot these movies in 15 16 days and we
need to get them out and we have fans
that we know we release the movie on one
day the next day they say where's the
next movie it takes five months to make
a movie at minimum and so we are trying
very hard to get them out as quickly as
possible so we need to make the
experience fun and we need to make sure
that we are all in this positive
creative environment so that we can
create the best movie short to and if
you're doing sensitive scenes where you
know maybe they're not nude but it's
still it's sensitive for an actor yeah
to have it where you feel safe that's so
saying I felt that when I watched the
behind scenes yeah just sort of a
feeling of being safe yeah it's very
important that the actors are
comfortable
on our set and our my crew is extremely
respectful and every single time we come
into any of these intimate scenes I have
a conversation with my actors I need to
make sure that they're comfortable we
will rehearse everything with clothes on
we will then move forward to starting to
take clothes off the sets are closed the
and we're constantly talking about where
a hand should be what it should be this
is not just you know willy-nilly go
ahead and try things we're very specific
on where the camera is what we'll do
where we're following hands and what I
want those hands to do so and I have to
make sure that both my male and female
actors actors feel comfortable with the
intimacy that I need to portray
you